(bouncy music)
- [Voiceover] This looks crazy.
- It does.
It looks like, this looks like something
you would have 3D printed.
- What is this?
Spicy roasted fish crackers.
- Ugh!
- These are your daily snacks.
It smells like a bait and tackle shop.
- Ooh, it's spicier than I thought.
- I don't like it.
- I like it!
- I don't taste the fish at all, actually.
- Does Indonesia know
what fish tastes like?
- I don't...
- They just smack fish on things and go,
like, yeah, sure.
- Chiki. Chiki Balls.
They're not afraid to use balls.
- Chiki Balls.
Do chickens have balls?
- Dude, it says balls.
- Actually, all it says is balls.
- It's like, it's a baby
chicken, eat my balls!
- Oh God.
- That's what he's saying.
- It's like a ball of dirt and cheese.
- Are they cheese or are they chicken?
- That's exactly what I
thought it would taste like.
- I mean--
- That guy's balls.
I mean...
- Taro Net.
It looks like a net.
Made of seaweed.
- This is like a real savory flavor.
It tastes almost like olives and pickles.
Not like pickles, but like olives.
Like olive oil.
- It tastes like seaweed crackers.
- It smells like Play-Doh.
- It does smell like Play-Doh.
But it doesn't taste like Play-doh,
and I know that 'cause
I used to eat Play-Doh.
- Everyone did. You're not special.
- [Voiceover] Cassava is also a root?
- [Voiceover] Yeah.
- Do you guys just not
have potatoes in Indonesia?
- Oh my man.
I'm not even going to
be able to taste this.
My mouth's already on fire.
- This is delicious.
- It is delicious.
How many calories are in this?
- What does this taste like?
- It tastes like cereal.
- 95 in--
- 95 calories.
- In 0.9 ounces?!
Oh, man.
- I don't even think you
could eat a whole bag,
'cause you eat one, you're just like...
- It's like a task.
- KuSuka chips.
Also the same as crack cocaine.
- Indestructable.
That's weird.
- This glaze is made out
of polymer, isn't it?
That's like the secret? It's plastic.
- Kukagumi!
Which is a fresh, daily snacks.
- I bet these make you (beep) a brick.
- When you're just hungry
for petrified styrofoam.
- They don't break up.
It's just cardboard.
- It smells like paint.
- It doesn't taste like anything!
- It tastes like styrofoam
with an aftertaste of fish.
Which is exactly what I want
my styrofoam to taste like.
- You could probably build
a building with this.
- Every single one of these things
has been harder than I thought.
- I am concerned we just ate stucco.
- Why would you eat this?
- Why did you eat two?
- I don't know!
- I am concerned we just ate stucco.